happy Sunday reject nation how you doing
guys we are going to do another movie
news of the week for all ten of you guys
happy you're here today well let's get
this show on the road for the first week
of April the biggest movie news we could
find on our end this week so early on in
the week the Russo brothers put out a
post on their Instagram about infinity
war it was a picture of Thanos with his
gauntlet all activated and he had a
letter in there the letter reads this to
the greatest fans in the world we're
about to embark on The Avengers infinity
war press tour we will be visiting fans
all over the world screening only a
limited amount a selected footage from
the film in order to avoid spoiling the
story for future viewers we will not
screen the film and its entirety until
the Los Angeles premiere shortly before
the film's global release everyone of
all that the film has worked incredibly
hard for the past two years maintaining
the highest level of secrecy only a
handful of people know the film's true
plot we're asking that when you see
infinity war in the coming months you
maintain the same level of secrecy so
that all fans can have an equal
experience when they watch it for the
first time don't spoil it for others the
same way you wouldn't want to spoil for
you good luck and happy viewing the
Russo brothers hash tag Thanos demands
your silence well that settles it all
trolls will not be spoiling the movie
now and in no way does this ignite a
trolls heart to go oh now I'm really
gonna spoil this movie and ruin it for
everybody nope nope nope the Russo
brothers have secured the secrecy of
spoilers all around the globe and this
is not gonna agon anyone good job Russo
brothers much better in my opinion
though this is this is actually a really
good marketing ploy because it just kind
of gets you more excited to see infinity
of orders are going there must be some
real [ __ ] going on in this movie
you know they are making a big deal out
of hiding all the surprises yeah like
that which suggests that there are
probably a great many of them yeah yes
you know III hope somebody takes this to
heart I don't think they will I think
we'll we'll have to do is go to our
channel keywords because it won't matter
what video we do we could do a video
about Ronda Rousey doing wrestling and
someone will leave an infinity war
spoiler on there you know people are
persistent about that shiz they are
persistent people you know what to
contribute to this we won't even do a
movie review no no no we won't do any
coverage of the actual movie just
reactions to the trailers so when we go
see it I'm not even gonna watch the
screen or listen to the sounds I'm gonna
watch the post-credits scenes yeah I'm
walking out right when I think the
movies gonna be finished yeah yeah yeah
hey if you missed the extra 10 minutes
or so okay yeah we're here to support
you Russo brothers speaking of not
spoiling anything oh boy some people
have seen the first 25 minutes of
infinity Borg I don't know where they
screamed this but some people were able
to go to a legit screening of the first
25 minutes and Tom Butler from Twitter
verified Tom Butler being Tom Butler
Fame UK Yahoo editor Tom Butler oh yes
right there I see it just saw 25 minutes
of infinity war can't say much was one
hell of a trip seeing Marvel characters
from all corners of the universe
crossing paths so much potential for
humor and the Russo brothers milked it
for every penny
Wow just in the first 25 minutes you see
all them in the first 25 minutes dan
that's oh that's a lot of a lot of
people right well like they got a lot of
stuff to do I'm not surprised ultimately
I wonder how that first 25 or so is
gonna play out because there's so much
to establish in the first act of your
movie
I gotta imagine we're gonna be hopping
around a whole lot see Digital Spy foam
says we've just seen 30 minutes of
Avengers infinity war can't say too much
but it's way ambitious it'll switch
tones between different groups the
guardian sequence had a very different
look feel and soundtrack to the New York
scenes and it's going to be funny still
no Hawkeye I find funny about the
infinity war promos this is the first
time
anyone has ever been excited to seeing
Hawkeye the most hype Hawkeye has gotten
mostly because he's nowhere to be found
yeah people want Hawkeye I bet this
makes Jeremy Renner feel really good
yeah unless he's not in the film at all
then that's gonna be problematic
Joe Doty says we saw 24 minutes of
Avengers infinity Wars oh whoa whoa is
it 24 25
I don't know and where did this 24 25 or
30 minutes come from it's funny in the
afternoon is epic and the villains look
spectacular Plus goatees Groot and the
sneak peak is more quotable than most
feature-length films Marvel fans are in
for a treat an amazing treat well this
is really good here because if I know
the way embargoes work and what Studios
allow you to say they let you be raw
honest about your feelings prior to
seeing a movie so we can take all these
without a grain of salt one yeah and you
got to remember that most of the best
and most potent opinions are formed out
of like 24 25 minutes use that image of
a movie it's not the whole thing that
we're looking at yeah I know because if
they have worries or if they were
concerned about anything they saw it
would be all over here it would
definitely yeah Disney really allows
that for especially for their bigger
can't can't say too much can't say yeah
I like this is every one of these begins
with can't say to mom like yes I get it
now we've been doing this for a couple
years I know you can't say too much and
to cap off our Infinity Ward news I put
out on our patreon what are some movie
news that you guys want us to talk about
and Steph Williams sent over this clip
to talk about
it's a 30-second clip of Peter Parker
the school bus scene which I am
interested to see because every time I
see that moment in the trailer I'm like
how is no one noticing Peter Bart Ehrman
no one spot him doing this you know all
right let's check it out
spidey-sense ooh I like the music Ned
Ned is always down Wow
[Music]
whoa not bad okay okay clearly that clip
was not cut up at all now fit the Graham
Norton Show is the exact pacing of the
scene that we're gonna get part of that
first 25 minutes ever but like surprise
we got okay like 45 characters usurp
everything they're scenes can be more
than 30 seconds we don't have breathing
room but the main reason I want to check
out the clip is to see how he got away
with this
but it makes sense that the run to the
back of the bus he moves fast enough to
get to the side doesn't the bus driver
still have a chance of noticing its kid
this is like yes but maybe in all the
frenzy and all the shouting and all the
chaos maybe the bus driver will chalk
that one up too I'm in a panic or it
might just have to be something that we
justify in our animal watching a
cinemasins video all right well cool
look cool clip you know what I'm not
sick of talking about oh oh Ray's
parents yeah anything related to the
last Jedi I hope we still talk about it
after solo I hope that when we see solo
we don't even talk about solo we just go
back to the last Jedi but who is snow
simon pegg who you know from films such
as Run Fatboy wrong says JJ Abrams
answer to Ray's parentage who was
different from the last Jedi but I never
with JJ client intended or at least what
was sort of being chucked around I'll
think that's been kind of undone
slightly by the last Jedi I don't know I
don't know hahaha I think unkar plutt is
raised or your father
unkar plutt was who he played in force
awakens there was some talk about you
know a kind of relevant lineage for her
but I honestly don't know and I don't
know if anybody knows who we shall see
yeah I love I love I love the I don't
knows that he's saying sure you don't
know it seems like simon Pegg's the one
like famous fanboy in the acting writing
community where the people just tell
them everything yeah i don't believe any
of these i don't know
I'm sure he's talked a good amount of
shop I was really new like what the
actual intention was sounds like Ray's
lineage probably had a more you know
what I I don't care anymore it doesn't
matter it just doesn't matter guys you
know what's important about that is is
ray-ray is important
her parents are hourly care cuz unless
they made her special that way unless
they are the key to understanding why
she's so good at all this Jedi stuff it
would have been cool to know and that's
about it yeah much worried this one when
I saw the force awakens I had an odd
sense of ennui during it I felt kind of
disappointed and I couldn't figure out
why and ended at the premiere and I felt
down and I was like why do I feel down
and I realized it was because I've been
in it I'd read the script and I'd even
contributed a little bit to the script
here and there so I've been involved in
it so it wasn't a big surprise so I
watched the movie knowing everything
that was gonna happen so when that big
thing happens to one of our favorite
ever characters it wasn't a surprise I
realized that the payoff for being in it
was to have the experience of seeing it
removed and I wouldn't swap that because
it was an amazing experience but it was
a strange one that's the price of being
behind the curtain I guess that's why
Jon and I are approaching our 30s and we
have yet to make a TV show or movie
mm-hmm cuz we don't want to ruin the
experience of watching things still yeah
but being involved will ruin the
surprise of anything we come up with
we'd rather just catch movies where we
go I had an idea like that - how many
years ago I should have written that
script yeah I'd rather be in that
position cuz I don't want to end up like
Simon Pegg well just never get involved
with making a Star Wars movie or any
other franchise that you care deeply
about we got some beef we got some beef
coming back up in the waters of the
Hollywood waves ya know what The Rock is
cooking it's some grain a usda-approved
baby yeah yup teas we saw rampage early
we will do a review next week and a
spoiler review with sammy gonzales
from double toasted look out next week
when he's in town on Friday
okay the rock as Duany johnson was
speaking with some reporter when it came
to most recent production the fate of
the furious Johnson Diesel did indeed
shoot their scene separately that's what
they address and he said that is correct
we were on any scenes together so what
exactly went down VIN and I had a few
discussions could an important
face-to-face in my trailer so one of
them broken left the roof I came to
realize that we have a fundamental
difference in philosophies on how we
approach moviemaking and collaborating
you're right I mean because the
mythology of The Fast & Furious films
can raise quite a debate the rate of
differences mam's create a major I want
to be in the film more no or more
invincible than you it took me some time
but I'm grateful for that clarity
whether we work together again or not
here's where it gets scary people
looking ahead to the ninth installment
whether or not Johnson will return for
that film he said I'm not quite sure
right now I'm constantly I'm making the
spin-off Hobbes the desolation of smaug
Hobbes and Shaw has good at can be but I
wish him all the best and I harbor no
ill we're there we'll just because of
the clarity we have actually you can
erase that last part about no ill will
will just keep it with a clarity they
really don't like each other maybe or or
this is just aa Stoke in that fire yeah
dokin that conflict fire there get some
gasoline here people uh how do we cure
the fire this is what happens when you
get a bunch of ego maniacs in one movie
together Tyrese Gibson hates the rock
and diesel in the rock hate each other
the rocks dominating in the rocks like
yo I have a harder work ethic than all
you guys if I'm gonna be the star faster
the figure it is now I'm gonna do this
then you got Michelle Rodriguez over
here like you're all voided out dudes
where
[ __ ] the only one driving Jordana
Brewster is at home I cannot wait to see
the Aaron Sorkin biopic of the behind
the scenes I would adore that move it's
weird have this movie's weird message is
about family here about like no one on I
Love Lucy got along with each other you
know that kind of thing everyone in the
band this is the vibe I'm getting with
this movie I don't really care about a
Hobson's shawl spin-off I don't even
really care about another Fast and
Furious right now it's like guys just
put your dicks to the side for a minute
and just make the movie who gives a damn
I don't know what kind of creative
differences he's talking about exactly I
don't know what sort of ethic he's
referring to but at a certain point I
feel like these movies need to mix it up
again because there's only so much they
can ride the current wave that they're
riding and part of that is like you said
I'm not really excited to have another
one of these so soon why don't you go
away for a minute and let us miss you
instead of like just delivering us a
steady chain of these mass-produced
movies I don't know something about that
line where he says actually you can
erase that last part about Noel we'll
we'll just keep it with the clarity yeah
that's that rubbed me wrong a little
that rubs me wrong in a way and that's
when it sounds like he's adding fuel to
the fire that's when I get the sense
that maybe you're being a bit of a dick
- maybe I mean I think in a real fight
the rock we win I just feel like to add
that was like I usually associate the
rock with a certain level of poise or
class and that was like that's it that's
a dig right there yeah there's nothing
wrong with Hobbes and Shaw spin off and
I think that if you take Vin Diesel out
of Fast and the Furious you are missing
something more than if you take the rock
out of it yeah because he joined on like
way after with all readiness when the
franchise got a big boost again with
part four is because Vin Diesel returned
that Vin Diesel and Paul Walker but
really like Vin Diesel's the lead you
might say that Vin Diesel is the engine
of and it seems like this is his mission
impossible yeah when I look at Vin
Diesel you know he seems to be the guy
who was like now we got to do these man
we got to keep it up like the family
I heard the big complaint was work ethic
and the rock is very anal about work
ethic which you know with a guy who's
juggling like 15 things at once you got
to be a guy who seems to have no
personal time oh yeah and workout time
well somehow we spend most of our time
on this one story I was gonna be us one
day I can't wait for that yeah we have
different opinions on our reactions
bedroom there's no well there's also
clarity but wait there is it will
scratch the part about the clarity -
yeah all right guys let's our movie news
of the week right here join us next week
as we talk about other movie news that
we definitely know what is coming out oh
yeah totally
cuz they give us the down low on
everything we get all the Nuvi news like
a week in advance before it hits the
presses so these are very prepared
subscribe to the reject nation people
click that notification bell so that
subscribe button is worth something also
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions plus weekly Q&A s + + +
stuff things